ah bonjour à tous excusez nous ça fait
partie des choses c'était pour savoir si
vous suiviez 6 a commencé bonjour
bienvenue dans le grand studio du figaro
il faut s'habituer un jour les voitures
ne feront plus de bruit et donc il
faudra s'habituer à bien regarder autour
de soi même plus se fier au bruit on est
en direct et j'espère que vous
m'entendez on est avec vous on est dans
figaro live en attend vos points de vue
approuvez-vous la mise en quarantaine
pour dissuader les français d'aller
skier à l'étranger c'est la question
qu'on vous pose en ce moment sur le site
du figaro et on va en débattre ce soir
on va en débattre avec claire chartier
rédactrice en chef à l'express ça je le
savais et auteur d'un livre très fort
très important très dérangeant aussi le
viol et nous une enquête sur un fléau
social c'est aux éditions de
l'observatoire et c'est impérativement à
lire
face à vous claire gabriel plus elle
vous connaissez bien
rédactrice en chef du site boulevard
voltaire et auteur d'enraciner elle a
aussi un très beau livre aux éditions
artège alors l'autre sujet qui vous
passionne aujourd'hui c'est tout ce qui
s'annonce autour de la vaccination et le
débat autour de la stratégie française
vous le savez vous le savez peut-être
pas mais la grande bretagne compte
démarrer la semaine prochaine sa
campagne de vaccination la russie aussi
la france elle attend plutôt janvier
alors question faut-il accéléré on
attend vos points de vue alors pour
l'instant
d'abord c'est une légère avance pour le
nom un peu plus de 53% au dernier
pointage j'ai la question d'hier devant
moi c'est pour ça je suis troublé mais
c'était 53% de non à la question je vous
le rappelle approuvez-vous la mise en
quarantaine pour dissuader les français
d'aller skier à l'étranger alors voici
comment déjà le premier ministre jean
castex vois les choses
il l'a redit chez jean jacques bourdin
ce matin l'idée c'est d'empêcher les
français d'aller se contaminer dans les
stations va instaurer du préfet des
départements limitrophes
ce qu'on appelle une quarantaine c'est à
dire qu'on fera des contrôles aléatoires
à la frontière que vous serez et placé
et que vous subirez les tests un
isolement de sept jours dans
l'opposition voici ce qu'en pense sans
attendre le républicain guillaume
pelletier
nous nous demandons avec les présidents
de région avec les parlementaires
ce soit eric pauget député des
alpes-maritimes
laurent wauquiez président d'auvergne
rhône alpes un sommet à matignon à
l'elysée que le président a vu qu
entendez rassemble l'ensemble des
personnes concernées et qu on puisse
avant noël ouvrir les stations de ski et
les remontées à travers un protocole
à travers un protocole sanitaire il y à
plus de 105 milles vous êtes plus déjà
plus de cent cinq mille à avoir voté à
la question du jour sur le figaro si
vous ne l'avez pas fait vous pouvez le
faire continuer à le faire et écouter
les arguments de claire et de gabrielle
claerr je commence avec vous vous placez
du côté de la répression jean castex ou
de l'ouverture version guillaume
pelletier c'est pas juste
je me pose la question alors évidemment
dans un premier temps on se dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça rentre ça
paraît très très très paternaliste mais
bon en même temps fermer les stations de
ski et se dire que espérer que les
français fassent montre d'un esprit de
responsabilité c'est quand même miser
sur je dirais le patriotisme des
français alors que bon puisqu'on peut
considérer que c'est quand même un
risque au vu de ce que l'on sait du
comportement des français et aussi au vu
de l'enjeu qui est quand même de lutter
le plus efficacement contre cette
pandémie alors je ne sais pas trop
effectivement quelles sont les mesures
là jean castex en a évoqué quelque chose
une ça peut être aussi la fermeture des
prendre des frontières il est certain
que ça renvoie l'image d'un gouvernement
très peu libérale qui collent pas tout à
fait avec l image d'un emmanuel macron
tel qu'il nous avait vendu pendant la
campagne et c'est vrai que c'est presque
même du caporalisme on a l'impression
d'un aller jusqu à commencer par le père
d'élise ray on peut considérer que c'est
certain en même temps il faut quand même
être conscient que les gens qui vont
être lésés par cette mesure c'est quand
même une petite portion on l'avait déjà
dit sur ce plateau
ça représente moins de 9% des français
ceux qui ont les possibilités d'aller
skier chaque année donc au regard du peu
de gens concernés par ces éventuelles
restrictions et au regard de l'enjeu
parce que si ces gens ces quelques
skieurs quand ils reviennent pardon je
termine quand ils reviennent de leur
station si on se prend un rebond de la
vague c a tellement tout le monde a ce
n'est pas simplement une petite mention
mais tout le monde vous pensez qu'il va
le train qui vous pensez comme frédéric
valletoux
républicains comme dit aux plantiers la
même chose apparemment marre d'entendre
ceux qui pleurent on va regarder le
tweet marre d'entendre ceux qui pleurent
le drame de leur séjour de ski reporter
leur immense malheur les empêche de voir
que les hôpitaux alpin saturé et que le
ski c'est chaque année plusieurs
milliers de blessés en plus alors oui
aller en montagne mais marcher ou pas
oui et je voudrais terminer je pense que
c'est important de réfléchir à ça je
suis fier qu'il tweet un pub et je
voulais finir ce plaisir c'est que
restreindre la liberté de quelques-uns
ça permet de protéger parfois aussi la
liberté la liberté du plus grand nombre
donc c'est comme ça qu'il faut à mon
avis réfléchir assez à ce genre de
dilemme
alors est-ce que c'est dans ces termes
que vous réfléchissez un achat gabriel
et est ce que vous me manqueriez de
patriotisme
puis 7 selon claire ce que fait le
gouvernement il en appelle au
patriotisme des français en demandant
d'aller skier
du côté de l'autre génère je peux en
parler d'autant plus librement que je ne
skie pas donc je ne prends pas c'est pas
un parti personnel mais je trouve pour
faire toujours très attention à ces
restrictions de liberté et à cet
argument connaissent consistant à dire
aux finalement ça ça re ça concerne pas
grand monde on va un peu dénigrer ce que
ça concerne ils sont riches ils veulent
et ce qu'ils peuvent bien sacrifier cela
et puis basta
alors c'est un peu comme la gestion de
la de l'interdiction de la messe
finalement et moi je trouve que c'est
une gestion extrêmement autoritaire et
répressive et qui donnerait si j'ose
dire être sur tille envie d'aller skier
et à kehl vain de revenir à la messe
voyez c'est à dire que on se dit mais où
est la cohérence dans tout ça on est
heureux d'apprendre que finalement et
ben bloquer les frontières les contrôler
et les tester c'est possible donc on
vient de l'apprendre ce n'était pas
possible pour les islamistes s'étaient
pas précis pour les chinois sont en tout
que le virus n'avait pas de passeport
mais finalement c'est possible pour les
skieurs donc c'est quand même
relativement dérangeant et peu cohérent
et j'avoue que moi je trouve qu'on
devrait se méfier de cette logique
j'avoue que je rejoins en cela laurent
wauquiez je comprends son argumentaire
qui consiste à dire ça ça concerne quand
même 250 stations 120 mille emplois
c'est quand même mieux
voilà la faction des nations oui mais
des restrictions elles s'accompagnent la
sphère me dire enfin en réalité est là
elle la justifie puisque on se rend
compte que l'on use d'un argument
sanitaire c'est à dire ouh là là
attention les gens qui vont aller ce qui
alex alain ferrand oui pas non non
samassa on voit bien très bien que ça
fonctionne ensemble et qu'on s'appuie
sur un argument comment dire sanitaire
que jusqu'à présent ne prenez pas du
tout en compte puisque emmanuel macron
encore au mois d'octobre quand il était
intervenu avait dit non non on va pas
mettre de de contrôler un train intra
européen et là tout d'un coup on décide
qu'on va en faire un simplement pour les
stations de ski et tout d'un coup elle
est rouge utile c'est ces cétacés
ça n'est pas assez c'est assez étrange
donc on voit bien que c'est une forme de
répression de punition ils vont aller au
coin ils vont aller en quarantaine s'ils
n'ont pas été gentil il s'en aller sans
rien
je remets un euro dans la machine france
de suisse
est ce que vous faites pas un peu la
fine bouche un peu comme comme françois
ruffin écouter ce qu'il a dit ce
printemps
moi je voudrais bien qu'il ya des
contrôles à l'entrée de nos frontières
sur les pneus en provenance de l'asie
par exemple puisque daniel spagnou
rennes lâché nous a parlé du pneu
asiatiques comme si c'était une espèce
de fléaux naturels comme le frelon donc
si on est capable de le faire sur les
gens qui vont skier à l'étranger et
c'est pas c'est pas mes copains qui vont
que ce qui a priori en suisse
mais si on est capable de faire ça je
vois pas pourquoi on n'est pas le plus
capable de le faire sur des conteneurs
avec des pneus par exemple
bon ben vous devriez être content tu
gagnes ajustements simple doyer pour le
retour à la frontière donc je fais jean
castex
je sais qu'on l'entend de façon en creux
avec françois ruffin mais c'est jour de
fête en effet il est rare que je sois
d'accord avec françois richard mais en
réalité ils adorent yadlin d'or avec
jean castex aussi qu'il avait établi ce
la frontière et non mais il rétablit la
frontière de façon extrêmement
arbitraire et ponctuel alors qu'il nous
a expliqué et c'est ça qui dérange parce
que si ça avait été le cas avant s'il
s'y laver comment dire promu la
fermeture de la frontière
précédemment on aurait pu se dire bon il
reste cohérent là c'est absolument et
cohérent parce que françois réfère à
raison on a le sentiment que l'ouverture
des frontières cesser ça peut être un
mal mais finalement on le subit parce
que c'est une fatalité moi c'est vrai
que ça fait dix mois que j'entends ah
bon on peut pas faire autrement ce
serait trop compliqué comment voulez
vous qu'on ferme les frontières on me
regarde comme si j'étais un parent iere
quand je l'imaginé que l'on pourrait
contrôler les frontières et là tout d'un
coup on voit que c'est possible donc ça
a quelque chose je dois dire de
prodigieusement agacé alors à ce moment
là en effet je vous retourne votre
question soyons d'accord avec castex
mais soyons d'accord avec lui jusqu'au
bout et fermont la frontière au
terrorisme aux islamistes aux migrants
que l'on n'arrive plus à contrôler et et
et pas seulement aux skieurs qui veulent
aller en suisse qui sont pas
spécialement non plus mes copains je
suis comme un franc [ __ ] fin je n'en
connais pas tant que ça finalement faire
du hors piste
alors il ya un certain nombre
d'ajustements d'intérêt d'internautes
qui paye justement participe à votre
débat que je salue notamment nicole il
ya cet autre internaute qui ne se
prennent en représente pas mais qui vous
interpelle
et gabriel et qui vous dit renseignez
vous un peu la suisse pour venir en
france il faut une preuve d'une
obligation idem pour la belgique donc ça
c'est pas la science parce que c'est pas
ce n'est pas l'europe donc là j'en
parlais de l'europe mais il ya donc
nicole qui nous dit exactement parfait
pas de fermeture des frontières au
printemps mais là on peut les contrôler
dans un précédent entretien qu'on avait
eue pendant justement le confinement
vous m'avez dit précisément clair ce
sont des souvenirs sont bons mais ils
sont bons sur cela que effectivement les
frontières on aurait dû dès le départ en
tout cas rétablir le contrôle et
rétablir le contrôle aux frontières sur
les gens qui arrivent et est ce que vous
pensez
mais encore une fois on est dans une
situation enfin parfaitement évolutive
ça c'est extrêmement enfin on l'a dit
mille fois je veux dire cette situation
est totalement inédite on est face à une
crise inédite et la france n'est pas la
seule à tâtonner la france n'est pas la
seule à proposer précisément de tester
de rétablir les frontières sur cette
question du ski l'italie leurs visages
l'allemagne aussi donc bon sont pas des
gouvernements particulièrement
liberticide donc je pense que
effectivement on est dans une espèce de
recherche de pragmatisme avec un
objectif encore une fois qui est premier
qui est sanitaire et qui peut justifier
certaines restrictions de liberté si ça
permet de préserver la liberté de tout
le monde parce qu'encore une fois ci on
a un rebond de cette pandémie faut être
très concret très pragmatique et là je
pense pas pas tellement idéologique
l'idéologie là dedans elle a pas
tellement de place c'est à dire que si
on a rebondi tout le monde va traquer on
va se ce devoir à nouveau se plier à un
confinement l'économie va être ravagé
encore davantage psychologiquement
l'état de des français va être encore
pire qu'aujourd'hui donc soyons un peu
concret donc complètement d'accord avec
vous il faut être absolument pragmatique
il faut sortir de l'idéologie et c'est
pour cela qu'il faut être logique parce
qu'elle pragmatique c'est être logique
donc on voit bien que cette mise en
quarantaine puisqu'elle n'a pas été mise
en place auparavant dans d'autres
situations qu'il justifiait puisque il
ya d'autres pays on peut imaginer que ce
serait intéressant de les contrôles à la
frontière et de les mettre en
quarantaine
plutôt que la de contrôler les français
qui reviennent eh bien on voit bien que
ce n'est pas qu'il n'y a pas une logique
d'ensemble et c'est ça qui pèche c'est à
dire que par exemple dans cette
incitation parce que cette quarantaine
procède de cela de cette incitation fait
aux français de ne pas aller skier en
espagne en italie en suisse
alors on apprend que emmanuel macron par
exemple inciterait pense crois que c'est
entendu sur rmc demandera à l'espagne de
faire en sorte que les français ne
puissent pas à l'éthique des espagnols
qui se fait en espagne pour elle à le
faire ça de façon courte et bien on voit
bien que c'est un peu le même la même
logique quand on a dit à ben puisque les
petits commerçants peuvent plus vendre
leurs articles et bien les grandes
surfaces n'auront plus le droit de
vendre leurs ardeurs
c'est une espèce de fuite en avant qui
défie toute logique c'est et j'avoue que
vous avez raison on peut dire depuis le
début et on le répète à raison que c'est
c'est compliqué de gérer cette crise
personne sans doute n'aimerait être à la
place du gouvernement il s'entoure doute
n'aurait-il pas souhaité mais ça
n'empêche pas un minimum de cohérence
et puis de redresser la barre quand on
sent que ce que l'on a fait était un peu
non ajustée hors on à la présente là
s'est montrée mais la fuite en avant je
crois que l'enjeu non le jeu n'en vaut
pas la chandelle
tout simplement puis on regarde la
population concernée le joue donc le
risque que l'on prend
non effectivement je suis là je rejoins
le gouvernement n'en vaut pas la
chandelle c'est à dire que permettre ce
exposées à ce risque de contamination
c'est ça que je veux dire pour une
portion congrue je vous dis pas qu'ils
sont partis clairement riches ou pauvres
c'est pas la question il ya aussi des
personnes modestes celui des seniors est
une des clés facile de stigmatiser les
skis ans encore une fois j'ai donc fais
ma maman dis donc il faut dire non ça
prive les gens d'aller skier allait bien
mais si on est d'accord mais je trouve
que vu le risque vu l'enjeu non sauf
qu'on voit bien que c'est une mesure de
rétorsion qui vise non
au fait que l'on a fermé les stations et
sa ferme et les stations c'est un
véritable enjeu économique
je veux simplement vous dire quelque
chose car c'est que vous partez du
postulat qui actuellement est discuté
c'est possible et on est en réalité on
le sera dans la maison du postulat selon
lequel ce le confinement tel qu'il est
mené actuellement serait l'alpha et
l'oméga de la solution pour lutter
contre le coronavirus la réalité c'est
qu'on ne le sait pas trop il ya un
certain de médecins qui disent peut-être
que ce confinement familiale non pelées
d'état de balivernes pour les oraisons
donc les uns et les autres on peut se
permettre de douter
donc en réalité sera la solution viendra
l'explication dans un 2 ans voit donc
imaginer que dans un ou deux ans on
ronge
on se rende compte que toutes ces
mesures économiques extrêmement stricte
la louve in a moment même nous rend
directement les noms mais la logique
veut que pardon juste la logique veut
simplement ça c'est tout à fait
compréhensible que pour limiter la
propagation d'un virus
il faut qu'un virus qui se propage en ce
en se portant sur les individus il faut
limiter les interactions sociales ça et
donc un confinement ça limite les
interactions sociales donc là de ce
point de vue là il n'y a pas tellement
un débat également sur quand il ya un
confinement qui limite les interactions
de champ social des interactions que ça
n'empêche pas c'est justement les
interactions familiale il ya là il ya
deux théories policière
il ya d'autres disent que justement ça
accélère mandat on avait quand même des
propos d'olivier verrons qui avait donné
cet argument là avant qu'on décide le
confinement sur le plateau de bfmtv
enfin bon encore une fois on peut
choisir la pire des jeux veut dire
évidemment il ya toujours des risques
parce que face à ça c'est impossible
d'avoir zéro
une précaution absolu concrètement et
c'est une question qui est posée par un
internaute effectivement que vous avez
déjà abordé tout à l'heure sur le cas de
l'espagne est l'exemple de l'espagne
mais qu'est ce qu'elle est ou faire pour
que va-t-on faire comment le
gouvernement peut concrètement faire
pour empêcher les français d'aller skier
dans des pays ord
or la suisse serre dans les pays
et de l'espace schengen c'est à dire
l'italie l'espagne bon l'allemagne où
l'on passé par l'allemagne pour aller en
autriche par exemple il peut les
dissuader je ne sais pas enfin l'agencé
ria en fait je ne sais pas qui à quoi
pensent exactement l'exécutif sur ces
questions là mais ils peuvent
oui enfin j'en sais rien je pense que
des tests à tour de bras séditieux c'est
dissuasif
effectivement si vous dit où je vais
rester en quarantaine parce que je sais
pas la quarantaine ça peut être aussi un
moyen dissuasif
certes il ya une autre question à une
autre objection d'un internaute c'est
comment savoir qui a été faire quoi à
l'étranger comment savoir si telle
personne est parti skier ou non et
comment le prouver
peut-être que quand vous passez oui oui
non c'est vrai quand vous passez la
frontière peut-être que vous devez à
tester toutes les personnes qui vont
sortir d'un sens vont être le risque
d'être testé ou d'être traqué ce qui est
curieux c'est que ce n'est pas
inintéressant comme méthode
en effet dans l'absolu si on sort de de
la faire du ski et de ce qui ressemble
quand même à une mesure de rétorsion dr
question pas vraiment avec ses skis sur
le toit de la voiture en passant la
frontière devient quand même facilement
suisse on oui voilà alors on peut
imaginer que les les
il ya tout un une méthode qui sera mise
en place pour traquer ces gens là faute
ou que ne l'at on fait avant c'est ce
qui est extrêmement surprenant c'est si
je prends un exemple précis récent qui a
beaucoup frappé et a raison c'est celui
et vous allez voir qu'il ya un lien
c'est celui du terroriste de nice qui
lui a été co vide positif quand il est
pas il a passé la frontière pour
commettre ses forfaits mais il était
aussi comme il peut citer ou qu'il y
aura eu un contrôle à ce moment là ça
aurait pu être intéressant parce qu'on
aurait fait d'une pierre deux coups et
là tout d'un coup donc cette mesure
aurait pu être intéressante mais on nous
a expliqué que finalement c'était pas
utile de l'apprendre ça fait depuis le
début de la crise et tout d'un coup pour
quelques skieurs qui supposément irait
passer la frontière parce qu'on a fermé
les stations de ski françaises pour
finalement les punir d'aller à
l'étranger parce que c'est cela et bien
on mettrait en place cette cette mesure
donc le skieur va être plus traqués je
caricature peut être un peu mais à peine
que l'islamiste qui passe les frontières
ou que le chinois au début de la crise
reconnaissez que ça quelque chose
d'incohérent vous savez quand on veut
qu'un pays adhère il faut qu'ils aient
une
une cohérence qui soit accessible que
les mesures soient accessibles au bon
sens et je crois que c'est un petit peu
ce qui passe dans la gestion de cette
crise avec 4 une objection par rapport à
ce que vous dites gabriel c'est ce que
nous dit cette internaute qui nous dit
bonjour bonjour avec respect
souvenez-vous des contaminations
l'ukraine rapporté par des gens bien
placés venu faire du ski en autriche
allemand je connais pas cette histoire
mais ce qu'ils on sait c'est qu'il y
avait un premier cluster 7 heures dans
le froid
en autriche on y avait un vous savez le
pardon ce foyer il est venu alors je me
souviens plus exactement de la station
dans le derby fois savez comment ça
c'est pas tellement parce que c'était
des skieurs c'est surtout parce qu'ils
allaient rester dans un bar il avait
quand même un drôle de moyens pour
prévenir le barman y jeter une balle
dans la queue de rattraper dans la
bouche le serveur donc effectivement
comme moyen de contamination c'était
s'était relativement aisée mais
maintenant c'est pas l'activité
elle-même cesser c'était une époque où
il ya eu des contaminations dans toutes
sortes de lui mais ce qui est vrai c'est
dans les premiers lieux de contamination
alors effectivement il ya eu à creil
dans l'oise dans le nord de la france
mais il ya eu également aux contamines
donc dans les alpes françaises et donc
c'était quand même des premières
contaminations des premiers premier
foyer c'était dans les stations de dans
des stations de sports d'hiver
et c'est bien pour ça que l'allemagne
d'ailleurs est favorable à cette mesure
là dont on parle oui même si c'est
effectivement est là elle a hérité de
deux d'allemandes qui était parti faire
du ski dans cette fameuse station et
mary chaîne du cou qui sont venus et qui
ont importé en fait le jeu mais vous
avez complètement raison mais c'est vrai
de beaucoup de lieux
on l'a dit aussi des évangéliques on l'a
dit mais c'était une époque
à une époque où on ne prenait aucune
précaution c'est à dire que on ne savait
pas que ce virus arrivé je disais qu'à
l'époque c'était un petit peu de la
responsabilité de l'europe ne l'avait
pas vu arriver
or là mais là les gens habitant je
disais donc raison crise pourraient
avoir injustement et ray est prudent
avec l'économique sa jambe et les gestes
de neige assez pour dernière question
mesdames pardonnez moi je vous coupe
sont mal élevés c'est curieux il ya des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants
nous dit liberté tous collés à paris par
contre aller au grand air sur un
télésiège là le gouvernement s'affole
rachel également qu'ils demandent
vaut-il mieux être dans les boutiques
les musées ou les théâtres ou à la
montagne au bonheur c'est pas le bonheur
qui pose problème à la montagne mais
sauf à tous que l'objection l'objection
pose ses internautes serre que 40000
personnes masquées
oui mais d'accord mais on se retrouve
effectivement face à toujours ce dilemme
cet arbitrage permanent c'est à dire que
si on continue à fermer sion si on
laissait les serres les commerces fermés
effectivement l'économie s'en relèverait
pas donc là c'est ainsi qu'en faveur des
élèves ne seraient pas c'est maintenant
la question est partout
oui mais par rapport aux stations de ski
c'est certain que ça grève fortement les
rentrées de ses stations là mais c'est
pas comparable
est ce que pour reprendre pour aller
dans le logique de cet internaute il ya
pas un rapport de force qui est pour
l'instant défavorable aux stations de
ski et les temps il ya quarante mille
personnes sont là qui manifestent en
plus contre les violences policières
bon bah là on va pas justement interdire
je sais pas je pense qu'ils ont ils ont
aussi effectivement beaucoup travaillé
avec le gouvernement ce qui est un peu
étonnant moi je ne discute pas en fait
du bien fondé la fermeture des stations
ce qui effectivement là enfin comment
dire je pense que ça mérite réflexion
parce qu'on pouvait imaginer toutes
sortes de choses et je crois que le
secteur d'ailleurs imaginer toutes
sortes de choses pour essayer de
préserver sa ce qui me paraît
intéressant à creuser cette question des
libertés
pour le reste ils ont je pense une
occasion de défendre leur point de vue
beaucoup
après ce que c'est toujours en
démocratie effectivement est ce que
c'est la rue qui qui c'est
le levier décisif en tout cas en causant
on pose la question on anime nous dit
pour le ski est là que partout donc il
ya des gros risques en plus de petits
logements alors moi je vous pose une
question à un ami c'est vrai ma le
souvenir que je ça fait longtemps quand
même je suis pas allé skier pour tout
vous dire aimer j'avais l'impression
qu'il y avait plus de monde en février
que à noël mais peut-être que je me
trompe
on donne mandera à nibards bastia qui
est la spécialiste du ski au figaro
justement sur ces questions là la
question qu'on pose sur le site du
figaro vous pouvez continuer à répondre
si vous n'avez pas déjà répondu que si
vous êtes déjà très nombreux à l'avoir
fait approuvez-vous la mise en
quarantaine pour dissuader les français
d'aller ce qui est à l'étranger et pour
l'instant donc c'est le nom qu'ils
l'emportent mais vous êtes assez
partagés 54% vous pouvez continuer à
voter
l'autre question c'est partager c'est
comme sur ce plateau est là où on à
50/50 bon l'autre question portait porte
et compose elle et elle est sur twitter
et elle porte sur la stratégie de
vaccination
on quitte pâle là que le corps d'un
virus ce soir la grande bretagne démarre
dès la semaine prochaine
vous le savez la lave sa campagne de
vaccination en tous les cas a donné son
feu vert pour que on utilise les vaccins
fabriqués et mise au point par le
laboratoire américain pfizer l'admirent
poutine lieu s'ils souhaitent commencer
une campagne de vaccination massive avec
son
vaccin pique nique pour la france ce
sera ce sera plus tard
en tout cas c'est ce qu'a annoncé ce
qu'on a pu entendre ces dernières heures
de la bouche les manuels macron aura
vraisemblablement une deuxième vague de
vaccination qui s'ouvrira quelque part
entre avril et juin qui elle sera plus
large et plus grand public et qui ira
vers une stratégie de vaccination du
plus grand nombre
et là aussi il revient à chacun d'eux le
pays de définir les règles de cette
stratégie
j'ai pu dire il ya quelques jours aux
françaises et aux français que n'auront
pas une stratégie de vaccination
obligatoire mais qu'on cherchera à
vacciner le plus grand nombre par une
stratégie de conviction et de
transparence mais ça ne sera pas si je
peux dire dès décembre janvier ce sera
plutôt quelque part autour du printemps
il évoque même la date de décembre
janvier on évoque plutôt la première une
première campagne de vaccination en
france en janvier claire le jdd vient de
publier le rapport parlementaire sur la
gestion de l'épidémie gestion alors au
sein rapporte n'est pas encore accepté
par les députés la république en marche
mais enfin on a quand même eu l'idée de
ce qu'ont pu dire certes les
parlementaires et de ce qu'ils ont pu
penser gestion chaotique et surtout
surtout un retard dans la prise en
charge un manque d'anticipation
alors est-ce qu'il faut cette fois c'est
ce qu'il faudrait pas cette fois-ci
accéléré comme le demandent notamment
game politique on a entendu tout à
l'heure où comme on le demande
aujourd'hui sur twitter
alors oui ce fameux retard à l'allumage
effectivement que critique qu'affronte
le gouvernement depuis pas mal de temps
alors il ya le gros la grosse difficulté
sur cette question là c'est que nous
sommes dans un pays où la défiance est
ravageuse plus que dans le reste des
pays européens et que si oui elle est
majoritaire elle est plus élevée donc
vraiment confiance dans beaucoup de
domaines envers le politique et envers
le pouvoir médical donc imaginer qu'on
se mette à vaccinés avec un vaccin qui
ne soit pas tout à fait au point
le risque que prendrait un gouvernement
a enclenché cette dynamique là avec
peut-être des effets secondaires
terrible dans un contexte où les le
complotisme se s'en donnent à coeur joie
pour dénoncer vous avez tous vu tous les
commentaires sur le le documentaire hold
up
voilà qui est quand même interdit sud de
contre vérités donc tout cela alimente
l'idée que le gouvernement pactisent
avec les laboratoires donc imaginer que
il se passe quoi que ce soit que le
vaccin soit pas au point ça serait
absolument terrifiant par ailleurs il me
semble bien que
tout cela s'inscrit dans une démarche
européenne puisque l'europe a passé des
accords avec des laboratoires de façon à
ce que tous les européens
au même moment et le vaccin donc ça
paraîtrait quand même assez curieux que
la france commence enfin tire la
première en quelque sorte alors que
s'engage une europe de la santé que nous
avons tous regretté
parce qu'elle n'existait pas par la
force des choses lors de la première
vague donc là c'est l'occasion d'agir
ensemble de façon concertée harmonieuse
et de renouer avec une idée qui est une
idée française parce que l'europe de la
santé en fait était un projet très bien
ficelé par un ministre français de la
santé dans les années 50 et qui n'a pas
pu voir le jour
parce que ça s'est perdu un peu pas par
manque d'adhésion ce parce que ça s'est
perdu un peu dans les méandres
technocratique donc là on a l'occasion
d'agir ensemble et en plus là encore une
fois je suis très prudente aujourd'hui
parce que c'est vraiment mon leitmotiv
mais je pense que par prudence et vu le
front des antilles vax qui s'est
constituée la des anti vaccins je pense
que ça serait absolument trop haut
risque ont joué notre partition où on
attend on joue l'europe de la santé on
attend pour commencer campagne de
vaccination c'est à dire que je pense
que ce qui va être extrêmement compliqué
en effet c'est l'adhésion on l'a dit
récemment c'est qu'un certain nombre de
français n'adhèrent pas et disent je l'
ai vu de nombreuses fois sur les réseaux
sociaux et dit ce sont les mêmes qui
finalement nous ont dit que les masques
étaient inutiles au mois de mars qui
nous disent aujourd'hui que le vaccin ne
risque rien donc il ya la parole de
comment dire public qui c'est qui a été
la parole de l'état qui a été
décrédibilisée
donc cela au moment de l'arrivée du
vaccin ça va faire évidemment des dégâts
par ailleurs on peut sur cette affaire
de vaccins et c'est pas du complotisme
se dire que il ya évidemment des enjeux
financiers autour qui ne sont pas
neutres et qu'ils interfèrent forcément
dans les décisions et c'est pas on pense
par exemple qu'il ya comment dire 500
mille doses de vaccins qui ont été
réservées par l'europe pour un budget
d'un milliard de jeudi ce pas un rêve d
hiver c'est quoi le nom oui ça ça et
puis là le ms dit que finalement bas ce
serait pas ce serait pas efficace donc
c'est un véritable enjeu il faut être
prudent
par ailleurs on sait tous les médecins
le disent que c'est pas la variole il ya
quand même même si c'est un virus
sérieux il ya une létalité qui est
faible notamment chez les jeunes et des
mutations je crois que le virus a lutté
cet oubli fois depuis le début donc
c'est un peu comme la grippe se sera pas
pour installer une immunité durable donc
risques et des effets secondaires
sachant qu'on a testé peu en matière
d'échantillonnage tant dans le nombre de
personnes testées que dans la durée
c'est à dire que même s'il y avait un
mort sur 10000 ou sur 100 millions à
mort ou des effets secondaires graves
sur 10000 ou sur cent mille personnes
vaccinées et bien sûr ce compte tenu
d'une comment dire d'une vaccination
massive se seraient déjà grave s'ils
avaient des effets secondaires à 10 ans
se serait déjà là donc il est évident
qu'il faut une extrême prudence le
rappelle je vous renvoie le vaccin
contre la dengue par exemple qui a fait
vous savez là d'un conte a entamé d une
vaccination massive notamment aux
philippines en 2017
on s'est rendu compte que finalement il
y avait une suractivité pour sûr
viralité pour des les primo affecté donc
c'est quelque chose d'un sujet sérieux
et c'est pas seulement des les
complotistes qui se disent il faut être
prudent évidemment
c'est pour ça qu'on avance et je n'en
suis pas et je dis qu'il faut être
prudent oui alors si va déjà se sont dit
que dès qu'il faut être prudent on est
compris si ça recommence est dit
une question qui est posée par nico sur
twitter puisque il répondait ce twittos
répondez à la question qu'on pose
justement sur la sur 7 sur cette affaire
faut-il accélérer la vaccination la
campagne de vaccination le contrôle
acolytes 10,9 en france et nico dit est
ce que ce qui pose cette question se
sont portés volontaires pour tester les
vaccins alors effectivement succès
l'origine de la question je ne me suis
pas encore porté volontaire mais ce que
vous allez vous précipiter sur le vaccin
en boucle non pour les réseaux enfin moi
je me vaccine tous les ans contre la
grecque donc je ne suis et je n'ai
aucune commande hier je n'ai pas de
prévention particulière envers les
vaccins
donc bon là pour les réserves que je
viens de dire je pense qu'effectivement
il faut qu'on soit certain il faut en la
matière une très grande pédagogie une
très grande clarté vu le contexte donc
j'attendrai que nous soyons sûrs et
j'attendrai effectivement le feu vert de
l'agencé européenne de la santé qui je
pense a le système de pharmacovigilance
vigilance qu'il faut pour estimer que là
ça y est le vaccin est suffisamment sûre
pour qu'on puisse le proposer à la
population générale
gabriel c'est diane qui lui dit mais
apparemment c'est plutôt votre temps
dans votre votre position il faut
prendre beaucoup plus de recul
oui alors moi non plus je ne suis pas
anti vaccins de principe j'ai un père
qui est médecin et qui a connu les
ravages de nom mais en l'occurrence il a
vu ce que c'était que la variole le
label la polio face à ces mêmes la
rougeole qui reste quand même la
première cause de mortalité infantile
dans le monde je crois donc je ne suis
pas un anti vaccins de principe mais je
pense que là aussi évidemment il faut
avoir du recul dans tous mes dents tout
médicament dans tout traitement dans
tout vaccin il ya la balance bénéfices
risques est aujourd'hui
il n'est pas montrée au vu de la
létalité de ce virus que ce bénéfice
cette balance soit en faveur du vaccin
d'autant que il me semblait bien me
semble bien avoir vu un sondage il ya
quelques mois qui donnait quand même
moins de gens méfiants envers le vaccin
qu'aujourd'hui s'est passé dans mon
souvenir de 40 à 60% aujourd'hui on a 60
% de gens qui ont des réserves sur la
vaccination
alors je sais je vais on va vérifier ses
larmes en souvenir c'était 2 55% mais 55
sans descendre skis plus que donc on
voit bien on voit bien que la méfiance
grande mais oui tout à l'heure excusez
moi mais je dépasse le cadre du vaccin
mais vous dites on imagine que on
n'imagine pas enfin en gros que le
gouvernement pactisent avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques mais je me
réfère enfin je leur disais oh oui c'est
la thèse oui mais quand je lis le
portrait qui fait de celui qu'on
présente comme le monsieur vaccins en
tous les cas la personne qui a été
chargé de mettre en place la stratégie
vaccinale depuis le mois d'octobre sous
la plume de quelqu'un qui n'est pas
complotistes qui est notre consoeur a
fait le baquet du monde et qui vous
présente quelqu'un qui a été le
directeur de cabinet de jean françois
mattei au moment de la de la crise de la
canicule donc quand même on se dit pas
que c'est une équipe qui gagne et
ensuite qui est quelqu'un qui a passé 2
qui est passé deux fois dans des oeufs
dans des laboratoires et qui a travaillé
pour un lobby qui a fait du lobbying
auprès des institutions européennes en
faveur de l'industrie pharmaceutique
avant de revenir dans la haute fonction
publique on peut pas dire qu'elle est
d'ailleurs c'est de la population pose
raphaëlle bacqué c'est peut-être qu'il
va un problème de conflit d'intérêts
dans cette affaire probablement
effectivement il est désigné comme tel
mais là en l'occurrence il s'agit de
trouver un vaccin un vaccin qui
fonctionne fort mais pas dans dans les
histoires qu'on a connu les années
précédentes
il ya même dizaines
né avec effectivement cet entremêlement
de conflit d'intérêts terrible tous là
ce sont des deux héros c'est pas que ça
ça peut justement sur wii pc oui bien
entendu et c'est absolument
enfin je trouve que ces funestes que se
retrouve avec ce type d'informations
mais il me semble là que le cadre est
différent je veux dire on a une course
au vaccin on a des laboratoires qui
effectivement il ya une guerre
commerciale indéniable de laboratoire
qui essayent de dégainer les premiers le
vaccin plus efficace et des
gouvernements qui tentent d'avoir les
meilleurs je pense que là c'est un cadre
très différents alors moi je crois que
là il faut faire attention de ne pas
comment dire éluder ces sujets en par
affecte c'est à dire en se disant c'est
très grave il faut trouver une solution
si on commence à évoquer ces sujets là
eh bien on va mettre en danger
potentiellement en parce que c'est un
peu ce que j'entends la petite musique
jeux que j'entends c'est à dire que l'on
met le doute on instille le doute dans
l'esprit des gens ils ne voudront plus
vague journée et et je crois qu'il faut
et il a parlé tout à l'heure du
documentaire je pense que c'est
important si vous voulez que les gens
croient à nouveau et confiance de ne pas
écarter du revers de la main toutes les
objections mais au contraire d'y
répondre point par point ne faisons pas
d'angélisme en effet ce sont des anges
et financiers trop fort et il ya un
certain nombre d'allers retours entre le
politique la médecine et le monde
industriel et commercial des
laboratoires pour ne pas imaginer ce
serait vraiment de l'angélisme qu' il
n'y a pas des collusions et comment dire
des conflits d'intérêts a scellé sa
nature est à en parler à n'importe quel
médecin ses concepteurs et 2 barges et
pas de pédagogie de totale transparence
et c'est bien pour ça aussi que tout à
l'heure je m'en suis référé à l'union
européenne et à son système de
pharmacovigilance et de de contrôle je
pense que c'est plus facile à cette
échelle-là de contrôler effectivement
les enjeux et les conflits éventuels
d'intérêt que haut niveau je dirais
nationale donc c'est bien dans cette
perspective là que je me plaçais je suis
absolument d'accord avec vous sur ce
point de consensus je donne la parole
aux internautes puisque marie amélie
pochet d'un mandat il me dit que déjà on
a dépassé de 5 minutes
le temps imparti mais je ne peux pas
faire soit on se quitte sans vous avoir
donné la parole
alors justement diane ou autre chose
promise chose due on vous a cité la
france connait non seulement une
troisième vague nous dit jean-michel
dues aux fêtes et aux congés d'hiver
connaîtra un enseignement mais une
quatrième quart peu iront se vacciner
est ce qu'on peut pas quand même rassuré
peut-être jean-michel alors je sais il
faut être prudent
n'ayant que peut-être il ya suffisamment
de monde entre les gens qui auront eu
déjà le
la maladie et ceux qui iront se faire
vacciner on peut peut-être parier sur
une sur une humilité collective
alors je pense que le terme la même les
scientifiques lé ce que se disent qu'on
va pas y arriver de sitôt immunité
collective mais en tout cas oui que ça
ça permettra effectivement d'endiguer un
petit peu oui je pense qu'on peut être
assez positif de ce côté là alors cet
autre internaute
il lui dit personnellement je me ferai
vacciner quand j'aurai pu constater
l'absence d'effets indésirables sur le
système immunitaire chez les autres
question subsidiaire d'ailleurs il faut
rendre obligatoire la vaccination dans
les ehpad ou pas notre point de vue dans
les ehpad dont je pense que c'est ça ce
serait là aussi je trouve qu'on a une
vision très bio jus biologique est
exclusivement biologique est
fondamentalement biologique et qui de
ces deux cette gestion de crise
notamment dans les ehpad et je crois que
c'est des articulations qui sont qui ont
le droit également deux heures d'avoir
un choix surtout à cet âge là ils ont eu
droit effectivement à ce quoi bon
choisir îlots pluie n'est pas tellement
emballé ne dit aucun recul sur les
effets secondaires vaccin cuisinés à la
va vite je passe mon tour avec respect
non plus n'est pas rassuré il paraît que
les soignants ne sont pas pressés de se
faire vacciner
je ne sais pas j'ai vu ça alors il ya
aussi il ya quand même une tradition
dans le corps médical de gens qui sont
il ya des médecins qui sont pour
évidemment il ya quand même de longue
date des médecins qui sont contre et des
personnels soignants qui sont contre la
vaccination a une histoire récente
mais peut-être aussi parce qu'ils savent
pour connaître le monde du médicament
qu'un médicament n'est pas un miracle et
que là encore ce jeu les dit tout à
l'heure c'est une balance bénéfices
risques qu'il faut peser et donc moi je
connais beaucoup de médecins de famille
pour un certain nombre de médicaments
qui disent il est urgent d'attendre
avant de se précipiter parce que
il y a des effets secondaires indéniable
donc je crois qu'il est de leur devoir
aussi sans hystérie collective de
prévenir des dangers c'est pour ça que
souvent on va chez le pharmacien c'est
pour faire valider le fait que les le
traitement que prescrit le médecin ce
qu'on m'avait pas fait a pris un anonyme
nous dit si le gouvernement on avait
acheté aucun vaccin il se ferait
également critiqué il n'ya pas celle de
bonnes conditions et nicole nous
demandent enfin pourquoi se focaliser
uniquement sur le vaccin et ne pas
chercher plutôt un traitement écouter
nicole c'est une excellente question je
vous fais une confidence moi aussi je me
la pose et je pense que c'est là matière
à un autre débat et donc je vous propose
de revenir très vite sur point de vue
nous on se retrouve demain soir merci
beaucoup clair
merci beaucoup gabriel et je recommande
vos livres sont très importants à lire
le violet nous enquête sur un fléau
social c'est aux éditions de
l'observatoire est enraciné sécher
partagent un cd artège voilà et bien
voici ce que il faut oublier pour noël
par les librairies ont rouvertes à très
vite sur figure live
[Musique]